foreign
County ruled that the elimination of
cash bail violated the Illinois state
constitution and then the Supreme Court
in our state upheld that or stated until
the full appellate process
could be heard uh we were very happy
about that as criminal justice leaders
in the state many of us opposed this
legislation based on the public safety
aspect we were very happy about the
decision what we're hoping for is that
that this issue is not politicized
there's a five to two Democrat to
Republican majority on the Illinois
Supreme Court we hope that the Illinois
Supreme Court takes a look at the
language in the State Constitution and
see how the elimination of cash bail in
Illinois is a clear violation of clear
language in the Constitution and that
they uphold the Kankakee County decision
a lot of the argument you hear from
those who support the elimination of
cash bail is the allegations that the
criminal justice system in Illinois and
across the nation is systemically racist
and discriminates against poor people
and that they believe this system will
stop that under our current cash bail
system the judge has the discretion to
release someone on their own
recognizance right now without posting
cash fail the defendant has the right
under the current system to petition the
court to say that they're Indigent or
cannot afford cash bail or cannot afford
an attorney so the system is already in
place with our current system to take
care of people who we claim to be poor
and obviously with the system based on
handling individual crimes in front of
the judge one defendant at a time but if
race is not factored into that at all
it's based on the evidence that's put to
the court on accusing the defendant of
the crime that they're charged with one
of the things that has not changed that
is still a problem is the potential of
disappointing peace officers based on
Anonymous complaints that is that
violates constitutional rights of a
peace officer who has the right of due
process to face their accuser and
of ideas so that that has remained
unchanged uh and a peace officer is not
a lower class citizen a peace officer
has the same constitutional rights as
every other citizen in this country and
then to suddenly say that they can be
disciplined based on an anonymous
complaint and the accuser does not have
to come forward
that's not constitutional
and it's not proper a lot of the things
that are in the safety act come from
Advocates that are anti-police they
believe the police are the bad guys
and the law enforcement leaders are
really tasked to align themselves with
this thinking not to think that there's
compromise when there's a group of
people that just believe that cops are
racist that cops are murderers that cops
are all these ugly things that you hear
about
from anti-polish people on social media
and other forms of media we can't
compromise with that we have to stand
for what's right and we have to stand by
what the truth is and the truth is if we
find a criminal justice employee who is
a racist we get we properly investigate
it and we fire them we get them out of
office because there's no room for that
but however we don't buckle or we don't
cave to Broad stroke statements that are
not backed by evidence saying that a
system is systemically this or that
without evidence to show
foreign